Hi, I'm Mano Marks.
This is the first episode in a
miniseries designed to show
you how to get started with the
Google Maps SDK for iOS.
In this episode, we'll look at
what you need to do to prepare
to develop your first
map application.
We'll go over downloading the
SDK, registering for an API
key, and making sure that you
have the right development
environment.
In step one, download the latest
version of the SDK from
developers.google.com.
This will be linked off
this page, which you
can click on now.
Once you have downloaded the
SDK, extract the archive and
put it in a folder where
you'll remember it.
For instance, you might have a
dedicated development folder.
Next, you'll need an API key for
use with your application.
The key allows your
application to use
the Google Maps SDK.
Without it, map data won't
download to your application.
To register for an API key, go
to the Google API console.
You can access it by clicking
on this link.
In the API console, either
select an existing project or
create a new one.
To create a new one, pull down
the project list and select
Create and give the
project a name.
Once you've selected a project,
select Services and
scroll down to the Google
Maps SDK for iOS.
Make sure that it
is turned on.
Next, click on API Access.
Scroll down and press
Create New iOS Key.
Enter the bundle identifier
you want to
associate with this key.
Bundle identifiers help
you identify your
application to iOS.
If you want to know more about
bundle identifiers, check out
this link from Apple's
documentation.
To follow along with the
rest of this video, add
com.example.SDKDemos to your
bundle identifiers.
You can also always come back
and add more bundle
identifiers later.
Finally, let's test
everything out.
There are different development
environments that
people used to code Objective-C
for iOS.
In this case, we'll
assume that you're
using Xcode on a Mac.
Make sure you have the latest
version of Xcode and the
latest iOS SDK.
If you need to get that set
up, check out this Getting
Started Guide from Apple.
Once you're set up, navigate to
the folder with the Google
Maps SDK for iOS that you
downloaded earlier.
In that folder, you'll find
another folder called Google
Maps SDK Demos.
Navigate to that folder.
In that folder, you'll see our
Google Maps SDK Demos Xcode
Project File.
Double-click on it to
open the project.
Select the SDKDemoAPIKey.h
file.
Go to the API console
and find your key.
Copy that and paste it into
this API key string.
This will allow all the demos
in your application to use
your API key.
Select a simulator
and click Run.
If you choose an iPad simulator,
you should see a
map with a Samples button
in the top left.
If you choose an iPhone
simulator, you should see a
table of sample options.
Select one of the samples
to see a map.
If the app runs but you don't
see a map, go back and check
to make sure your key was
set up correctly.
If everything's working,
explore the samples.
This should give you
a good idea of the
capabilities of the SDK.